to discuss the tariffs and more we are
joined by Time magazine executive editor
Bend Ben Goldberger Ben good morning
morning let's start right there Natalie
just mentioned there is a new potential
trade agreement the North American trade
agreement on the table
we heard the Mexican president respond
what was the White House's political
thinking with this as to the trade
agreement this essentially drops a bomb
on it but the calculus in the White
House is that the president can use the
blunt force of tariffs to force
concessions on otherwise unrelated issue
but that unrelated issue migration from
our southern border is core to president
Trump's political identity it has been
both a personal fixation and a political
cause and it's something that has been
bothering him his inability to stop the
flow of migrants through our border has
perturbed him since he has taken office
and so now he's betting that he can
essentially captivate Mexico's attention
with something that otherwise seemed
like a totally settled issue a revised
trade agreement right with tariffs it's
an alarmist measure as we saw in them
the markets didn't like this idea even
some Republicans don't like this idea
and I've said so openly this is the
pushback gonna make any difference to
the White House
well pushback within the White House
hasn't made any difference I mean some
of the presidents top advisors including
his son-in-law Jared Kushner as Treasury
secretary Steve munition were strongly
opposed to the imposition of these
tariffs but the president has long been
a believer in these exact tactics he was
advocating for tariffs on the Japanese
as a private citizen in the 1980s he is
convinced that they work and no one
whether they're in his party or not has
been able to get him to believe
otherwise moving on now to the Russia
investigation a prominent figure we've
all been waiting to hear from Robert
Muller came out essentially said what he
meant to say or at least you know but
really is it the distinction between did
he make the distinction between an
independent Council and a special a
special counsel here I think that's
actually a really important point that's
lost on many many people because Robert
Muller was operating under
the special counsel statutes which bind
him much much more closely to Department
of Justice code and regulations and he
believed that he was following their
procedures where as his predecessors as
independent counsels operated under what
was actually a different legal statute
that allowed them much more leeway and
it's important remember that Kenneth
Starr in his investigation of Bill
Clinton actually issued specific
possible impeachment counts that the
Congress could take up Muller obviously
was far more circumspect Berger we thank
you for your insight into an already
busy week behind us